le changement climatique
je vois qu'on est bien d'accord vous
dites qu'est-ce qu'on va encore
apprendre de nouveaux ce soir sur ce
grand sujet d'actualité
vous vous dites peut-être aussi encore
quelqu'un qui va nous faire culpabiliser
nous dire qu'on prend trop l'avion
comment je trouve le viande quand
détruit la planète
ben je suis pas venu pour ça ce soir
non je suis pas venu pour ça je pense
qu'on a tous compris qu'on avait un
problème en fait enfin presque tout
donc
récemment il y a encore une étude qui
est parue consortium de chercheur à la
fois des statistiquesiens et des
climatologues qui sont arrivés à la
conclusion que
pour que l'humanité ne soit pas
responsable du changement climatique la
probabilité est de
0,005%. donc comme dit l'astrophysicien
Aurélien Barraud très engagé dans le
écologie
lisez maintenant sur le fait que c'est
pas de notre faute le changement
climatique c'est quand même à Paris
risqué
donc voilà maintenant on explore des
solutions il y en a qui mis sur la
technologie on a vu Elon Musk par
exemple proposer 100 millions de dollars
à qui trouverait la solution contre le
changement climatique comme s'il
existait un remède miracle donc le
changement climatique on peut miser sur
la technologie c'est possible on crée
des machines qui capte du CO2 qui lui
fait changer de forme ensuite on le en
pièce tout ça dans le sol c'est possible
mais je trouve ça un peu dommage en fait
parce que il y a déjà dans la nature une
machine qui fait ça une plante un arbre
elle fait ça pour nous gratuitement
et puis en plus elle a juste besoin du
soleil pas besoin de lui fournir
d'énergie
donc quand on pense à ça on pense tout
de suite à la forêt amazonienne c'est
ces immenses forêts à protéger
absolument bien sûr le poumon de
l'humanité qui abrite des milliers
d'espèces d'animaux et de plantes
mais il y a une autre fabuleuse machine
à capter du CO2 et celle-là on y pense
moins
elle nous rend un nombre incalculable de
service d'épidémie
cette machine elle couvre 70% de la
planète
cette machine c'est l'océan
l'océan on a l'habitude de dire un océan
parce que toutes les mers du globe sont
reliées de manière ou d'une autre et
puis
cette océan abrite des écosystèmes qui
sont des champions du monde de la
séquestration du carbone on appelle ça
des écosystèmes de carbone bleu
dans les zones tropicales c'est les
mangues on a aussi les prés salés ou ces
immenses forêts de forêts de Calpe comme
on les appelle des macroalgues c'est des
paysages magnifiques très politiques
et puis en Méditerranée on a la
posidonie la posidonie c'est la déesse
de la Méditerranée c'est une plante à
fleurs marines qui forment de vastes
herbiers comme ça visible depuis
l'espace
et puis elle nous rend de nombreux
services sans jamais demander un centime
elle purifie l'eau par filtration elle
stabilise les plages elle protège en
fait la côte contre l'érosion elle sert
aussi de nurserie pour des centaines
d'espèces de poissons et crustacés qui
vivent dans les premiers stades de leur
vie
c'est le véritable nurserie pour toutes
ces espèces dans certaines qui sont
d'intérêt commercial
et puis c'est la championne toute
catégorie de la captation du carbone
elle est capable de capter jusqu'à trois
fois la quantité de carbone qui est
piégée par la forêt amazonienne pour la
même surface
sur toute la couverture des Herbiers en
Méditerranée chaque année c'est 4
millions de tonnes de CO2 qui est
capturé en fait ça représente les
émissions les émissions de CO2 de toute
la population du Valais chaque année
malheureusement on détruit ses
écosystèmes là partout dans le monde un
rythme effréné en Méditerranée on estime
qu'on a perdu jusqu'à 30% de la
couverture des Herbiers pour des 50
dernières années et puis la cause
principale de cet arrachage de ce
désastre c'est l'ancrage des navires en
fait plus la vie est grand plus la
chaîne est longue plus l'encre est
grande et plus les fonds marins sont
élaborés
donc maintenant la question qu'on s'est
posée c'est comment valoriser ce trésor
sous-marin que je viens de vous vanter
là comment donner un prix en fait à ses
services qui nous sont rendus par la
nature
et bien on dispose d'un outil qui est la
tonne de CO2 c'est une monnaie d'échange
internationale et c'est un système qui a
déjà fait ses preuves dans le milieu
terrestre dans le milieu forestier par
exemple
est-ce que quand on détruit la forêt on
libère du CO2 on crée une nouvelle
source d'émission le CO2 comme comme le
transport la version par exemple donc
protéger la forêt ou protéger les
herbiers c'est en fait empêcher des
émissions de CO2 ces émissions on peut
les quantifier on peut les mesurer
scientifiquement
et ensuite les convertir en crédit
carbone qu'on va pouvoir vendre aux
entreprises qui veulent diminuer leur
empreinte carbone les entreprises qui
visent à neutralité carbone pour faire
ça de manière éthique bien sûr avec des
entreprises qui cherchent d'abord à
réduire leurs émissions et puis la part
qu'elle ne peut pas réduire la compenser
avec ces crédits carbone on va financer
directement des actions de protection
dans la conservation marine
comme les bateaux c'est le premier
problème il faut qu'on crée des parkings
pour les bateaux en fait parce que vous
imaginez comment ville si on interdit
aux voitures de ce parquet sur le
trottoir et puis on propose pas de
parking forcément ça va pas marcher
c'est ce qui se passe en mer la
posidonie c'est une espèce protégée mais
malheureusement il y a pas de parking
donc on utilise son encre et en
malheureusement là pour les fonds
il y a tout un travail aussi d'éducation
et de sensibilisation à faire parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte dans nos
sondages que la plupart des plaisanciers
n'étaient pas forcément au courant du
problème en fait quand on ramène son
encre il y a des faisceaux de petits
Dany qui traînent on se dit que c'est
une algue ou de l'herbe ça repousse vite
en réalité la croissance de la plante
est très lente
et puis en fait la bonne image c'est
comme si vous allez faire un pique-nique
en forêt puis que vous faites une grande
tranchée dans le sol en détruisant
toutes les plantes tous les animaux qui
vivent ça ne viendrait pas l'idée de
faire ça pourtant c'est ce qui se passe
tous les jours en Méditerranée à cause
de la plaisance
ensuite après la sensibilisation on peut
imaginer de restaurer les zones abîmées
donc là c'est vraiment comme quand on
replante des arbres sur Terre on peut
replanter de la polyédonie sous l'eau
faire véritablement de la reforestation
marine et les techniques qui font qui
ont fait leur preuve qui montre des
résultats déjà intéressants
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
peut faire
en plus c'est bien parce que ça renforce
l'air bien quand il y a une tranchée
dans l'herbier l'érosion elle a
accélérée et la destruction accélérée
donc de replanter au milieu de la
tranchée ça renforce l'air bien et ça
ralentisse sa destruction
donc ce que je vous propose là vous
remarquerez que il y a rien à inventé
que c'est pas c'est pas technologique en
fait on a les machines qui captent le
carbone on sait comment protéger on sait
comment sensibiliser et on sait comment
restaurer
et peut-être que là on va aller on se
dit qu'on est peut-être un peu loin de
la mer et ça nous concerne pas
directement mais là on est face à un
problème mondial et si déjà j'ai pu vous
parler de ça et vous m'avez offert votre
écoute et puis que vous êtes déjà
conscient que sous l'eau il y a quelque
chose de qui a autant de valeur que sur
terre déjà pour moi c'est une partie du
combat qui a gagné
et puis qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aussi
on peut se demander ce qu'on peut faire
en tant que citoyen ben c'est choisir ce
qu'on achète choisir les entreprises qui
ont une réelle démarche donc
compensation carbone pas juste pour
l'image et qui est pas d'impact derrière
il y a un moyen de certifier tout ça on
peut se renseigner on peut soutenir ces
entreprises là
donc voilà je pense que on a tout
maintenant il y a plus qu'à
alors j'ai envie de dire osons et merci
de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]